[Music]
there's a
bunch of packages in here from the
netherlands
so we're looking for narcotics
[Music]
anyway in europe are pretty good
packages to check
so here we have great britain
this is a package for the uk
physical
so you got a package coming from
netherlands says it has documents in it
[Music]
that looks like a cd case but inside
there's no cd
doesn't look right
so we're gonna take a look at that one
i don't see any documents in here if
you're buying a video game
it's not gonna be blank like this and
this is puffy
there's red flags all over this
something interesting
there's a rocky substance
we see a lot of mdma from the
netherlands
the person has put cards inside
thanking them for being a good customer
they're not gonna get this order
[Music]
now we're gonna test what we thought was
mdma
just need a little sample we don't need
much
positive for mdma ecstasy
but this is a schedule one so it's gonna
be seized
and it'll be destroyed
[Music]
you